you
a mother always wonders when her child
comes home in tears what this Ches
swimsuit now that's a reaction tears
help sometimes for Kay today it's a real
tragedy she'd set her heart on making
the high school swim team
trouble is she tires so quickly these
days
even the coach season it's hard to take
that kind of disappointment when you're
just 15 Eddie Roberts she knows she'll
never get to know him if she doesn't
make the team
too bad Kay but that's the way it is and
even Mother Love can't change it
your family well Kay the women just
don't have the strength for sports and
swimming
what k you don't think anyone should
have to feel this way you're going to
see a doctor k that school nurse is
talking nonsense she just doesn't
understand money for doctors doesn't
come easy when you're a widow not unless
you catch yourself some nice widower
like Mr Mac next door
so you might just as well accept
yourself the way you are
forget the sports which is it going to
be k the weak woman bit or a doctor
hello this is Kay riddle speaking I want
to make an appointment I want to see dr.
Harris
named Kay riddle sex female age 15
primary symptom fatigue diagnosis well
let's see now
oh the report on the urinalysis we
better have the lab run a glucose
tolerance test on Kay
meanwhile though well it looks as if
Kay's had good reason to feel tired from
her urinalysis and symptoms there's a
strong suspicion she has diabetes Kay's
scared so their mother actually diabetes
is just a chronic disease Kay's body
doesn't break down sugars and fats
efficiently they aren't converted into
energy so they collect in her system and
make her sick uncontrolled it's a pretty
serious proposition the whole idea still
upsets mrs. riddle her grandmother and
her aunt Phebe both died of diabetes
that sheds more light on Kay's case
diabetes is hereditary it runs in
families but all mrs. riddle can think
about is the troubled grandma and aunt
Phebe had with their starvation diets
back when she was a girl of course
insulin takes care of all that now but
mama just bears down on how Aunt Phebe
used to go into diabetic comas comas yet
there's no reason in the world for
anyone to go into a diabetic coma these
days not with proper care that's why
it's so important to put Kay under
treatment right away before she gets
into real trouble before complications
develop but try to get mrs. riddle to
pay attention to a doctor like she keeps
telling you she's live with diabetes
she knows trouble is mama riddle knows
so many things that just aren't so even
worse she does not know three facts key
points all of them fact 1 diabetes is a
disease like any other a chronic disease
you get when a gland called the pancreas
doesn't work right fact 2 diabetes can
be controlled diabetics lead normal
happy lives once the disease is detected
and properly treated fact 3 control is
fairly easy diet exercise
insulin that's all it takes Ches a smart
girl so she follows orders
takes it for granted dr. Harris knows
what he's talking about there's a daily
test for sugar it isn't difficult by one
method you simply dip a strip of special
tape in urine then match it to a color
chart other tests follow other
procedures but they all serve the same
purpose they help the diabetic to keep a
constant check on his own condition
missus riddle tries to go along though
she does think this urine business is
well a little vulgar maybe miss Wiley
the public health nurse teaches Kay how
to inject insulin properly the shots
help make up for Kay's pancreas not
working right and she finds they don't
even hurt very much to prevent infection
equipment must be sterilized
continuing to follow the public health
nurses directions k loads the syringe
with the correct type of insulin air is
expelled
the skin is cleaned with alcohol k
places the shot carefully in order to
reduce discomfort and avoid sores and
scars
finally she makes the injection good
girl Kay you're an apt pupil the very
thought of the needle gives mrs. riddled
cold chills but Kay figures mama feels
more real pain just plucking your
eyebrows than anyone possibly could
suffer from insulin injections
another thing that bothers mrs. riddle
is the way Kay has to watch her diet or
a girl she has to deprive herself of so
much
no more double-dip helpings of mashed
potatoes no more ladles of thick brown
gravy no more rich cream sauces no more
drowning vegetables in butter actually
Kay doesn't like all such gooey glop she
doesn't feel as if she's starving either
breakfast Kay's certainly wasn't skimpy
her luncheon didn't leave her weak
dinners satisfying - and yes Kay can
have mashed potatoes within limits
butter biscuits French dressing
even luscious fresh fruits for dessert
but you can't convince mama she's sure
Kay's starving to death and she eats
twice as much herself to make up for it
between meals even more so it helps sue
their nerves when she gets to worrying
over the cost of Kay's diabetes why
should the child have to keep running to
the doctor and for ever buying insulin
of course mrs. riddles going to spend
more money needlessly today on glassware
than Kay's medical expenses for a whole
month but momma still wants Kay to ask
dr. Harris if she has to come so often
but Kay thinks health is worth a little
money she does what dr. Harris tells her
soon her tests are negative
a diabetic out-of-control
is thirsty all the time before treatment
K put a pitcher beside her bed every
night you drink a lot
well excessive urination is another
major symptom of diabetes
but that's all past now cage sleep
straight through her weight goes up the
way it should for a growing girl
diabetic or not and once she's on target
all she has to do is hold her own energy
comes with control and that shows up on
a girl's report card
kay feels fine too soon she's right back
in the swim with Eddie Roberts miss
Blake the swimming instructor notices
how she's improving and so does miss
Wiley the public health nurse
there's even a compliment from mr. Mac K
learns that the country has nearly 2
million diabetics and the million of
them still don't know it
mrs. Sorensen's case was detected when
public health officials checked birth
records
mrs. Sorensen's oldest son weighed 11
pounds 2 ounces at birth a child that
heavy indicates to doctors that there
may be diabetes in the family at the
County Health Department a screening
blood sugar estimation showed it was
likely mrs. Sorensen had diabetes so she
was referred to her family physician for
diagnosis and treatment
her doctor recommended that she attend a
Health Department class for diabetics K
soon learns that in the young diabetes
is a matter of life or death if it isn't
detected and controlled the victim dies
in the older diabetic the uncontrolled
disease may bring complications
hardening of the arteries blindness
gangrene heart attacks and strokes where
K is underweight the older diabetic
frequently is overweight and because
symptoms build up slowly often the older
diabetic doesn't even know that he's in
trouble
that's why diabetes is so dangerous in
the middle years people just won't
believe they have the disease till too
late after complications may have done
damage that can't be repaired can
diabetics have children mrs. Campbell's
healthy happy family gives the answer to
that question mrs. Lawson offers living
proof that diabetics needn't die young
mr. groves built up a big successful
business
Frank Hoover has a different kind of job
but even on the road all the time doing
heavy work and eating at restaurants he
still keeps his diabetes under control
it all helps Kay to see how important
prompt action proper care are to a
diabetic when she suddenly feels weak
while shopping k realizes that extra
exercise has brought on a mild insulin
reaction so she doesn't waste time gets
to a drugstore for a glass of orange
juice
good work kay but what if you hadn't
been near a drugstore what if you'd
passed out maybe it's time you filled
out your diabetic identification card
carry hard candy to help counteract
insulin reactions be sure to get the
type of insulin prescribed diabetes
affects circulation so to avoid gangrene
proper care of the feet is important but
mama is Kay's biggest problem she likes
being fat and happy she says she's not
about to waste time on a check for
diabetes heredity familial tendencies
that's a lot of nonsense
what if grandma did have diabetes and
aunt Phebe cousin Sam to symptoms mama
isn't bothered by excessive thirst and
urination she doesn't feel so well
sometimes - mama that's just the woman's
weakness she claims runs in her family
well yes her weight is up just a little
is it any wonder the fact is in
diabetics over 40 symptoms often don't
show up clearly enough for the patient
to recognize them but mama won't listen
to such talk no siree that's not for
Mama not while they're still syrup left
in the pitcher
kay herself make steady progress there's
even some slight chance she may not need
to take insulin too long diet alone
might hold the line as it does for many
older diabetics Kay's reaching top form
in the pool to miss Blake wants her to
swim in the chorus at the water carnival
and Eddie Roberts himself is going to
coach ER later when Eddie asks her for a
date
well the riddle house is hardly big
enough to hold her only somehow
that just seems to upset mrs. riddle all
she can think about is how her little
girl is growing up well Kay's got her
own ideas on that mr. Mac sitting right
next door and could be that he and Mama
cave that's ridiculous mr. Mac never
given mama a second glance that way well
after all mama the way you look now mr.
Mac probably figures he couldn't pay the
grocery bills cave that wasn't the thing
to say really it wasn't no Kay no you're
only making it worse don't you dare tell
your mother that no man wants to try to
support an elephant these days
especially not a sick elephant that
maybe got uncontrolled diabetes now mama
Kay didn't mean anything she loves you
she's just worried about your health
and besides mr. Mack really is a pretty
nice fellow
this is my rib cage mother I want to
make an appointment with dr. Harris